[müzik]
Evet. Absinin gülü yargurdum. Hadi
bismillah. Şimdi geldim neye? İlk çay
yukarlıklarından Mezopotamya'yla
Anadolu'yu hallettik mi? Ünite bitti.
Gitti. Şimdi geldim. Gel Zomzomla beni
Erdem Şoyanla. Mezopotamya uygarlıkları
abim bunlar 5 deneler. Tamam mı? Burayı
bazı meslektaşlar bu kodlar sabah e
falan diye ama tarih öğretmeni, sosyal
öğretmeni, sıv öğretmeni arkadaşlarım
siz diyorsanız burayı kronolojik
sorarlar size. O yüzden burayı her türlü
şeyle kodleyeceğiz diye uğraşmayın. Ama
Sümer işte Asur, Akat, Elam, Babil diye
bu böyle olduğunu bilin. Sıralamada her
kitapta farklı farklıdır. İlkinin Sümer
olduğunu bilin. Benim için yeterli.
Tamam. Çünkü soru gelirse nereden
gelecek? Sümerlerden gelecek. Çünkü
sordu. Eee
mesela yukarı banttan bir sınavda dedi
ki yazı ilk kez nerede bulundu dedi.
Aşağı mazipotam, yukarı Mezpotam, orta
Mezpotam, güney Mezpotam, sağ, solipotam
lan sümerler nerede? Harita bilmeni de
istiyor işte senden. Anlaştık. Hani bu
map kitaplarında haritalar mevcut. Şimdi
Mezopotamya dediğin yer. Soru gelir. Lan
bu Mezopotamya neresi? Neresi? İki tane
nehrin arası. Bir yanda akan benim öbür
yanda mesela o değil. O Sakarya'ydı o.
Mesopotamya neresi? Fırat Nehri ile
Dicle Nehri'nin suladığı o süper verimli
toprakları Anadolu'dan aşağıya doğru
geliyor ya işte orası Mezopotamya.
Günümüzdeki o Irak'ı al şeye al. Surenin
bir kısmısını alta aşağıya kadar indir.
Tamam. Hah. Şimdi burada süper tarım var
mı? Var. Niye? İki tane aslan gibi nehir
orayı besliyor değil mi? Süper tarım
var. Ama mesela Mezopotamya'dan günümüze
mimari yapı gelmedi. Niye? İki sebep
var. Bir kardeş burada süper tarım
yapılınca sürekli istila olur mu? Olur.
O dönem millet abim üreteceğiz. Neye
gerek var? Razı üreten var. Çök gitsin
oraya. Sürekli istila var. Ve günümüze
gelmemesinin sebeplerinden biri bu
istilalardan biri Moğollar. Moğol taş
üstünde taş omuz üstünde baş bırakmıyor.
Yıktı, yuvaladı gitti. Hiçbir şey
bırakmadı. Bir de dayanıksız malzemeler.
La orada taş yok. Taş. Taş. Dayanıksız
malzemeler. Kerpiçten. Anladık. Onlar da
bir zaman sonra ne oldu? yıkıldı gitti.
Dayanıksız malzemeler kullanmışlar.
Günümüze o yüzden gelmedi. Çıkmış
sorudur. Bir de şunu sordu. Mezopotamya
aşağı yukarı diye ayrılıyor. Neye göre
ayrılıyor diye sordu. Neye göre
ayrılıyor? Irmakların
akış yönüne göre. Irmakların akış yönüne
göre. A yukarıdan Anadolu'dan geliyor
değil mi? Aşağıya doğru. E ora yukarı
mazamaya. Burası aşağı mazatamaya.
günümüzde bile aynıdır. Irmakların akış
yönüne göre diye. Şimdi buradan
bileceğimiz ilki ve en önemlisi en çok
sorular karşınıza gelecek hangisiddir?
Sümerlerdir. Sümerler abeciğim site
denilen şehir devletleriyle
yönetildiler. Bak bu siteyi gördük mü?
Bu şehir devletini gördük mü?
Yorumlarımız hep aynı olacak. Ne
diyeceğiz? Merkezi otorite yok. Siyasi
birlik yok. Niye? Çünkü her şehir bir
neymiş? Siteymiş. Değil mi? İşte Lagaş
kralı, Urgut ne bilen ne kralı, Uğur,
Lagaş, bir sürü neyi var bunların. Her
şehir kendince birine bir devlet değil
mi? Hah. Ama başta despot zalim bir adam
yoksa özgür düşünce, bilim gelişir
diyeceğiz. Anlaştık. Sorunun gelişine
göre yorumlayacağız. Bak en sona zaten o
şedretlerini orada sana sıralayıverdim.
Tamam. Beraberinde bunların başında
patesi ensi denilen ne varmış? Krallar
varmış. Kralın adına bak. Patesi, ensi.
Patesi kalın, ensisi kalın. aklında
kalsın diye söylüyorum. Ama bu kral aynı
zamanda baş rahip, başargıç, başkomutan,
başkral, baş her bir zıkkım. Al sana 10
numara ne var? 10 numara monarşi var.
Doğru mu? Dediği yedik, çaldığı düdük
mü? Ama bir sıkıntı daha var. Adam aynı
zamanda da dini ne? Lider değil mi? Aynı
zamanda da ne? Hukuki, aynı zamanda
askeri, aynı zamanda kral. İşte şu din
de işin içinde olursa o yönetimin adı
neydi? Teokrasi idi. Değil mi? Dine
dayalı yönetim. Monarşi olduğu gibi
teokratik monarşi illa biri olacak diye
kaide yok. Bu monarşi birleşebilir.
Teokratik monarşi olabilir. Teokratik
işte şey olabilir değil mi? Mesela
meşruti monarşi olabilir. Biraz sonra da
onları da anlatıvereceğim. Tamam bilin.
Ve bunlardan gelecek. Patishengisi falan
salla gitsin. Bunlardan gelecek. Soru
abem belli. Bir zikkurat. Bunlar 7 katlı
tapınak yapmışlar. Şöyle a şuraya müthiş
mühendislik mimarlık belcerimle beraber
şöyle 7 katlı. Kaç oldu? 1 2 3 4 5.
Şuraya bir kaçak kat. Şuraya da bir tane
koyduk mu? Al bitti sana. 7 katlı
tapınak değil mi? Bunlar ne? Bunlar
birer tapınaktır. Zikkurat dediğiniz en
üstte de rahipler var. Bu tapınaklar çok
amaçlı kullanılıyor. Birinci katı
atıyorum kiler olarak kullanıyor. Millet
ürettiğini buraya getiriyor. İkinci kat
okul. 3 en son kat rasathane gözlem evi.
4 kat PlayStation internet kafe. 5. kat
salonu. 6. kat kuaför gibi. Ama ne
olarak kullanılmıyor? Bunu sordu.
Anladın mı? Bunu sordu. Saray olarak
kullanılmıyor. Niye? Kralın sarayı ayrı.
Anlaştık. Burası çok amaçlı toplumsal
bir yer olarak kullanılıyor. Ama işin
ilginç tarafı şu be adam laş yok. Yedi
katlı şey nasıl yapıyorsun? Sümerlerin
Türk olduğuna dair tezler de ortaya
atıldı ama henüz bilimsel olarak
ispatlanmadı. Mesela Gılgamış Tufan
Destanı Sümer ait diye anlatılır. Elbet
eserinde de geçer karşınıza gelir yani
hani ama işte bilin ama buradan
bilinecek bu Zikkurat tapınağı bak
sorarsa bunu sorar. Bak Sümerlere ait 7
katlı oynar başlıklı çok amaçlı
tapınağın adı nedir? Zikurat 7 katlı
tapınak. Şimdi bu adamlar gökyüzünde
astronomi tanrımızı arıyoruz derken
herifler neyi buldular? Ayyılı esaslı
takvimi buldular. E bu da gitti
Müslümanlar aldı hicri takvim oldu.
Mısırlılar güneş yılını bulduydu.
Romalılar aldı millet takvimi oldu.
Sümerler ayıl esas takvimi buldu,
Müslümanlar aldı. Hicri takvim oldu.
Dünyanın yarısı şunları bunları
kullanıyor. Anlaştık bilin. Ve bir de
burada olay ortaya çıktı. Şimdi
bunlarda, bu Sümerlerde malikül mülk
anlayışı var. Yani mülk Allah'ındır.
Herkes ürettiğini nereye getiriyor?
Tapınaktaki kilere getiriyor. İyi de
kimin ne getirdiğini nereden bileceğiz?
Millet ürettiğini tamam mı? Çeyindir,
taprangındır deyip herkes bu alıyor
oraya geliyor. Değişik bir ekonomik yapı
düzeni var. İyi de nereden bileceğiz
değil mi? Her getiren için abim bunlar
bir semboller kullanmaya başlamışlar.
Mesela ben uzun boylu,
uzun burunlu, geniş omuzlu ben kaslı
değil mi? Çok çalışkan olduğum için
yarım çuval getirdim. Al C. Anladın mı?
Bizim Aker kısa boylu, güpeli değil mi?
Eee, kısa pantolon giyiyor. O da
çalışkan. O da yarım çuval getirdi. Al
bu. A, anladın. Ondan sonrasında falan
derken böyle böyle ve öbürküsü işte
şişman o değil mi? Saçlar böyle uzun
uzun böyle o 5 çuval getirdi falan
derken hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Herifler
böyle simge, sembol bilmem ne yapıyoruz
derken la herifler neyi buldular?
Herifler yazıyı buldular. Yazı ilk kez
nerede bulundu? Sümerlerle beraber Güney
Mezopotamya'da bulundu. Aşağı
Mezopotamya'da bulundu. Yazı vereyim.
Bunlar Mezopotamya'nın neresinde?
güneyinde yani aşağısında sosyal
öğretmenlerine alan sınavında sordu
bunu. Yazı nereden çıkmıştır diye.
Güneye Mezopotamya aşağı Mesopotam diye.
Al o dönem kağıt var mı yok? Neye
yazıyorlar? Kil tableten yazıyorlar. Ama
yazıyı bulmakla da bunlar bir şeyi
başlattılar. Tarisi dönemler bitti.
Yontuktaş, cilalı taş, ne bilem ne taş,
Bakırtaş, ızıkkımtaş bitti. Ne başladı?
Tarihi
devirler
başladı. Şimdi buradan gelecek soru
tipi.
Gelecek soru tipi. Mezopotamya ile
Anadolu'yu karşılaştırmalı sorarlar. Kim
daha ileri? Anadolu mu, Mezopotamya mı?
Kim daha ileri? Mezopotamya daha
ileridir. Neden? Çünkü onlarda tarihi
devirler daha önce başlamış. Do you
under sheitent? Yattı mı aklına?
Anlayabildin mi? Bilin. Hayırlı uğurlu
olsun. Yazı güney Mezopotamya'da
Sümerlerle beraber başladı. İlk çağa ilk
giren de kim oldu? Sümerler oldu.
Anlaştık. Hah. Yazı bilimi falan
bunlarla beraber başlayacak. Tamam. Ama
bir de bunlarda yukarı banttan bir olay
var. Ne o? Mabet sosyalizmi diye bir şey
var. Ne lan bu mabet sosyalizmi?
Sosyalizm ne bu? Mabet dediğin ne
tapınak dediğin? Nasıl bu şey? Bu şöyle
hani bunlar da ürettiklerini kilere
getiriyorlar ya. Herkes getirdiği kilere
verdi, verdi verdi verdi verdi verdi,
verdi verdi. Ulan iktisadi ekonomi güç
kimde? Zikkurat'ın rahiplerinde. E kral
ne işe yarıyor? Kral kralın bir halta
yaradığı yok. Güç ekonomi dengesinde
kime kayıyor? din adamlarına doğru
kayıyor. Tamam kral, baş rahip falan ama
kardeş gönülden ırak olan şeyden de işte
zikkurattan tapınaktan kırak olursan e
sen de gidersin. Rai oradaki işlerin
üstüne çökmeye başladılar. Bunun üstüne
Lagaş Kralı Urgak Kina tarihte bilinen
ilk yazılı kanunları yaptı. Kanun
yapacağından değil kendini koltuğunu
tahtını rahata alabilmek. Şu mabet
sosyalizmi yani rahiplerin gelen
ürünlerle beraber güçlenmesini
önleyebilmek. İpler elinde kalsın diye
tarihte bilinen ilk yazılı kanunlar
yaptı. Ama bu kanunlar fidye esaslıdır.
Ne demek fidye esaslı? İnsancıl suçun
bir neyi var? Suçun bir bedeli var
mesela. Tamam. Ne o? İşte atıyorum
birinin camını mı kırdın, arabasını mı
kırdın? Yaptırıyorsun işte sana. Bak,
insancıl, fidye esaslı kanunlar
dediğiniz ilk yazılı kanunlar kimle
beraber başladı? Sümerlerle beraber
başladı. Daha ben alta yazarım buraya.
İlk savaş arabasını kullandılar, bilmem
tanrıları şunlardı falan diye. Gerek yok
abim. Anladın? Gılgamış tufan
destanlarının bunlara ait olduğu ileri
sürülür diye. Ama Sümerlerin iyi
olduğunu bil. Sümerlerden bilmek
istediğim iki mesele var. Birincisi şu
zikkurat denilen tapınak. Tamam. Çok
amaçlı kullanıldığını bil. Saray
olmadığını bil. İkincisi ise yazıyı
buldular. Tarihi devirler başladı. Şu
site mite muhabbeti de kulağında kalsın
şehir aleti diye. Tamam bilin. Sonra
akatlar var. Gel orta kameraya. Gel
orta. Orta kamera gel bu yanına öbür
zomzoma gel. Akatları alıyor mu buradan?
Bakalım bir alıyor. Tamam al. Akatlar
başkentleri agade. Bunlar tarihte
bilinen ilk imparatorluk diye geçiyor.
Kral Sargon var başlarında. Tamam. İlk
imparatorluk. İlk düzenli ordu mesela
kimlerde? Akatlarla beraber. Bunu
aslında biliyorsunuz. Akrep kral diye
bir film var. Bildin mi? Akatlı bir
savaşçıdır. Bunlarda önemli olan sağlam
savaşçı olman lazım. İlk böyle merkezi
imparatorluk, ilk böyle şey eee ordu
işleri bunlarla olduğu bilinir.
Sümerlerle de mesela devletleşmenin
başladığı bilinir ama şehir devleti
şeklinde örgütlenmişler. Anlaştık bilin
ayrıntısına. Gerek yok. Bilm gerek yok.
Asurlar gene önemli uygarlıklardan
birisi sorulursa zaten ya Sümer ya Asur
bunlar gelir. Asurlar başkent Ninova.
Bak Sümerlerde şehir devleti başkent
yok. Siyasi birlik merkez otorite yok
ama Akatlarda başkent var. Asularda
başkent var. Bak yan tarafta da onlardan
bahsedvereceğim. İşte MEBIN kitabı
burları hep ayırmış. Ben hepsini tek
seferde anlatıyorum sana. Asurlar da
kara kolonicilik yaptılar. Kolonicilik
illa Denizli'de olacak diye bir kaide
yok. Karada da yaparsın. Adamlar Anadolu
şeyin ortasında. Tamam. Karada yapmışlar
bu sömürgeciliği. Karum denilen pazar
yerleri kurdular. Soruldu. Karum denilen
pazar. Bunlar Anadolu'ya da geldiler.
Koloncilik yapıyorlar ya. Anadolu'dan
hala sömürülecekleri var mı? Yok.
Anadolu'ya da geldiler. Kayseri
Kültepe'ye pazar yerleri kurdular ama
asurdular. Gele gide gele gide bir şeyi
de getirdiler. Neyi getirdiler? Kil
tabletleri yani Anadolu'ya neyi getirdi?
Asurlular Anadolu'ya yazıyı getirdiler.
Böylece Anadolu'da tarihi devirleri kim
başlattı?
Anadolu'da tarihi devirleri Aular
başlattı. İşte bunu sorarlar. Anlaştık.
Bunu bileceksin. Bak bilin dediğim yeri
bilirseniz bu iş olur. Ha hocam nasıl
aklımıza tutacağız? Küçük bilgi
kartlarına yaz. At kavanoza arada
karıştır çek. Emin ol aklına gelecek
sorulursa bunlar sorulur. İşte bak ilk
kütüphane kurulmuş bilmem ayrıntı bilgi
isteyene doğru dünya yani hani şunu
bileceksiniz Anadolu'ya. Şimdi bir
dakika önce kim geçiyor tarihi devlere
ilk çağa? Mezopotamya geçiyor. Sonra
Anadolu gelecek değil mi? Kim daha
ileri? Mezopotamya mı Anadolu mu? Kim
daha ileri? Mezopotamya daha ileride.
Anlaştık. Mantık olarak anlayın.
Beraberinde Babil. Başkent Babil.
Babil'in meşhur asma bahçeleri var. İşte
bu Kral Nabuketzar mıydı, yenge miydi
neydi? Onun memleket hasret çekiyor diye
asma bahçeleri yapmış. Bu böyle bir yer
yok. Tamam mı? Kitaplarda onlar da
bunlar da anlatıla anlatıla ballandırıla
ballandırıla dünyanın 7 harikası
içindeydi. Artık çıktı o 72'de mi
2007'de mi ne değişti. Türkiye'den
birkaç yer vardı. Artık Türkiye'den bir
yer de yok. Yani
ödev verdim buranın altına. Eski 7
harikayla yeni 7 harikayı yazan
AYT'de matematiği, edebiyatı, fiziği,
kimyayı, biyolojiyi fulletsin inşallah.
Hayır duası. Bak neyi yazacaksın? Eski
yeni dünyanın 7 harikasıyla yeni
dünyanın yedi harikasını yaz. Bitti
gitti. Bak hayır duamı al. Bu kadar
basit abi. Bu kadar basit. Bilin.
Ama Babillerden bilinecek bir önemli
olay daha var. Bunların bir kralı var.
Kim o? Hammur abi. Hamur abi değil.
Hammur abi. Bu adam tarihte bilen ilk
anayasayı yaptı. Sert kanunlar. Bunlar
ne diye geçer? Kısasa
kısas diye geçer. Arapların dediği gibi
mendakka dukka eden bulur gibi bir
manası var. Ne demek o? Ben birini mi
dövdün seni döverler? Birini mi kestin
seni keserler? Birini mi öldürdün? Seni
öldürdüler. Birini mi ettin seni
ederler. Böyle ya ne yaptıysan
karşılığını aynen görürsün. sert
kanunlardır bilin. Tarihin ilk anayasası
olarak da geçer Babi kralı Hamur abinin
kanunları. Tamam mı? Yoksa bunların şeir
rezbetle uğraşmayın ve storytim. Siz
seversiniz. Siz bu Hammur abiyi
biliyorsunuz. Bu adam dinler tarihinde
de geçer. Bu adam dinler tarihinde
Nemrut diye geçiyor. Bildiniz mi o
Nemrudu? Bildiniz mi? Hani Hazreti
İbrahim'i ateşe atan Hz. İbrahim
geliyor. Bir Allah var diyor. E bu Hamur
abiler bunlar hep aynı mantık işte.
Hepsi aynı kaba. kişi ne diyor? Ben
kralım, ben firavunum, ben. Din adamı da
benim, baş rahip de benim, tanrı da
benin, haşa o da benin, bu da benin. E
bu modtalar değil mi? Hazreti İbrahim'i
ortadan kaldıracak. Tamam. Bu Urfa'nın
orada çok büyük bir çukur gazdırıyor bu
adam. Müthiş bir çukur gazdırıyor ve o
çukurun içine etrafta ne kadar ağaç,
odun, kömür yakacak ne varsa kapkacak
dahil her şeyleri ateşe attırıyor. Ateş
o kadar büyüyor, o kadar harlanıyor ki
lan ateşe yüzlerce metre yaklaşamıyorsun
bile. O kadar büyük birine ateş. En son
Hazreti İbrahim'i de tutuyor mancınıkla.
Hop nereye atıyor? Ateşin içine atıyor.
Değil mi? Parantez. Bu arada bir tane
karınca ağzına bir su almış. O da kendi
gücünce ateşe doğru giderken yanındaki
hayvanlar görüyor. Lan karınca Antman
what are you doing? Ne yapıyorsun lan
sen? Geri zekalı dediklerinde diyor ki
İbrahim ateş yakmasın diye ağzımla su
taşıyorum diyor. Diğer hayvanlar
gülüyor. Ha ha. Lan dingil senin ağzın
senin şuncacık ağzınla o koca ateş söner
mi dediklerinde karıncanın verdiği cevap
açık ve net. My side is defined. Türkçe
meali. Benim safım belli. Benim tarafım
belli. Hakla batılın arasındaki savaşta
biz kimden tarafız? Haktan tarafız.
Anladın? Mutlakta ora kazanır mı? Mutlak
da orası kazanır. Değil mi? Ve Hz.
İbrahim ateşe atıldığında Hz. İbrahim
3,5 toplu saltoya atıp tam suya
girecekken şey tam ateşe girecekken ateş
birden suya odunlar da neye dönüşüyor?
Balığa dönüşüyor. Al. Urfa Balıklık
gölünün hikayesi işte sana anladın yani.
Ve ama bir zaman sonrasında hatta sonra
Nemrut tamam burnundan sinek mi
giriyordu? Firavun muydu bu muydu bu
diye aklımda kalmış benim. Burnundan
sinek giriyor kafasını tokmaklattıra
tokmaklatıra duvarlara vura vura vura
kendini öldürüyor. Bu aklınızda kalsın.
Ve sonra bir olay daha var burada. Şimdi
bizim o Urfa, Adana, Antep o coğrafyanın
insanı. Et mi yer, ot mu yer? E et yer.
Değil mi? Et yiyecek de ulan mangal ocak
başa edeceğiz de yakacak. Bir de bir şey
kalmamış ki. Nemrut Hamur abi hepsini
yakmış. E ne edecekler ya? İşte bizim
insanımız isotla acıyla yoğura yoğura
yoğura yoğura eti acıyla yoğura yoğura
pişirdiler. Çiğköftenin nasıl çıktığını
anladın mı? Yattı mı aklına?
Gayet de mantıklı anlattım. Peki yuttun
mu?
Yutmadın mı? Tamam. Durdur. Alt tab yap.
Aç bakalım. Ara bakalım. Eğer anlattığım
hikaye doğruysa. Tamam. Bak bana yaklaş.
Eğer anlattığım hikaye doğruysa
öğretmenim senden şüphe ettiğim için
kendimden
utanıyorum. Resmini Instagram'ın da
paylaş. Aç bak ben beklerim. Sıkıntı
yok. Ben acelem yok benim. Erdem la
canım çekti. Bir çiğ köfte mi yoğursak
la?
Baktın mı?
Doğru muymuş la? Doğru olmasa ben
burada. Anladır mıyım kurban olduğumun
ya? Ben de oradaydım. Tamam. Ben de
böyle benim de kovalarla suyla ben de
koşturuyordum oraya. Nereden bileceksin
yoksa? Ben de oradaydım. Anladın mı? Al
çiğköfte hikayesi de budur.
Arkadaşlarınıza böyle anlatın. Bilgiyi
kullandığınızda güzel olur. Aynısını
benim sana yaptığımı sen de onlara yap.
Ya inanmıyor musun ya? Çok cahilsin
dostum ya. Ya günümüz internet, dijital
çağ ya yapay zekaya çıp diye sorsana de.
Benim videoyu gösteriyor da. Tamam. Al
haklı aklınızda bulunsun. Kısasa kısas
Babil aklınıza yattı mı? Bu kadar bitti.
Sonra Elam en sevdiğim uygarlık da bu.
Başkentleri sus
bitti. Haklarında fazla bilgi yok. Oh
kurban olduğumun en sevdiğim devlet. Ama
sadece buradan bunlar beşte ya. Sümer,
Asur, Babil, Akat, Elam teneler ya. Soru
hangisi Mezopotamya uygarlığı değildir?
Tamam mı? Araya Anadolu'dakilerden
birini kaktırıverirler. Hitit, Frik,
Lidya, İyon, Urartu değil mi? Bunlardan
birisini getirirler. Sadece dikkat
edersen yakalarsın. Mesoakları bu kadar.
Ama buradan bileceğiniz orta kameraya
gelir misin Erdem? Buradan bileceğiniz
olay şu. Gelin ortaya. Buradan
bileceğiniz olay şu. Sümerler. Tamam.
Zikkurat denilen tapınak çivi yazısı.
beraberinde Asurların Kayseri Kültepe'ye
Karum denilen pazarla yazıyı getirmesi
dönüyor dolaşıyor bunlar. Tamam. Şu işte
Anadolu'da çiv yazısı şey Mezopat'de çiv
yazısı güneyinde Urgak Kina'nın
kanunları işte Hamur abinin kanunları
bunlar karşılaştırmalı sorular tarzında
gelir karşınıza. Bu taraftaki Zomasına
gel Erdem. Hah şimdi geldim neye? Şu
şehir devletiyle. Tamam mı? Burayı da
MEB'in kitabı işte ilk çağdaki ticaret
havzaları. İlk çağdaki işte şehir
devletleri, ilk çağdaki yönetim anlayışı
falan diye, ticaret merkezi falan diye
vermiş. Bak şehir devleti. Mısır'dakinin
adı neydi? Nom. Nomosu. Yunan'dakinin
adı neydi? Polisti. Sümerler de neydi?
Siteydi. Değil mi? Bu şehir devletini
görürsek ne diyeceğiz? Siyasi birlik
yok, merkezi otorite yok. Başta despot
zalım dediği dedik çaldığı düdük bir
adam yoksa da ne diyeceğiz? Bilim
düşünce ortamı gelişir diyeceğiz.
Anlaştık. Ve Merkez Otorite ÖSYM'nin en
çok sorduğu yorumlardan birisi. Eğer bir
yerde başkent varsa, ülke eyaletlere
bölündüyse, başına vali ve onu
denetleyen memurlar gönderildiyse, posta
teşkilatı varsa, yol yapımı varsa bunlar
neyle alakalıdır? merkezi otoritenin
korunmasıyla alakalıdır. Anlaştık mı?
Bak nokta atışı bilgiler size. Ve son
olarak bir de burada şunlardan
bahsedivereceğim. Monarşi tek kişinin
yönetimi. Tek kişi. Tek kişi. Mesela
Osmanlı'da padişah monarşi dediği dedik
çaldığı düdük. Anladın mı? Mesela
Asurlarda işte atıyorum Akatlarda kral
sargon monarşi dediydik. Tek adam varsa.
Tamam. Peki oligarşi ne? Oligarşi işe.
Bu da çok kişi. Bunun çok örneği yok.
Bunun için günümüzde olmaz bu. Neden?
Çünkü bunun için yani herkes yönetici,
herkes kral gibi düşün. Bu antik
Yunan'da, İsveç kantonlarında 50 300 500
kişi yaşıyor. Herkes cumhurbaşkanı.
Tamam mı? Bunun örneği çok yok artık
günümüzde. Eskiden vardı işte o şeyde
Antik Yunan'da birkaç yer gösterilir
oraya. O Solon Kristenes'in 400 500
meclisi, İsveç kantonları mı ne onlar
günümüzde yok yani. Herkes yönetici. Çok
kişi yönetiyor ülkeyi. 400'ler meclisi,
500ler meclisi gibi günümüzde yok. Peki
teokrasi neydi? Teokrasi ise dile dayalı
yönetimdi. Yani şimdi illa şu olacak
değil. Bak monarşi ile teokrasi
birleşebilir mi? birleşir. Teokratik
monarşi. Bizim Osmanlı'da hem padişah
hem halife. Al sana teokratik monarşi.
Beraberinde Sümerlerde hem kral hem
rahip. Teokratik monarşi. Anladın?
Mısır'da frevun hem ben tanrıyım diyor
hem kralım diyor değil mi? Al sana.
Teokratik monarşi. Böyle bilin.
Anlaştık. ve beraberinde meşrutiyet ise
bu da şudur. Meşrutiyet halkın da
yönetime katılmasıdır. Halkın meclis
aracılığıyla
yönetime katılmasıdır. Mesela Osmanlı'da
meşrutiyet Abdülhamit zamanında ilan
edildi. Padişah var. Bir de padişahın
yanında halkın seçtiği meclis var. Seçim
kim seçiyor? Halk. Böylece yönetime,
böylece yönetime padişahla beraber kim
de katılıyor? Halk da katılıyor, değil
mi? Yani Osmanlı'da meşruti monarşi de
var mıymış? Varmış. Teokrasi de var
mıymış? Yani Osmanlı Devleti aynı
zamanda meşruti, monarşi ve teokrasiyle
yönetilen bir devletmiş. Hem dine
dayalı, hem tek kişi, hem de halkın
yönetime katıldığı sistem. Nokta atışı.
Aklınıza yattı mı? Anlayabildiniz mi? He
mi? He burayı da böylece bitirdik.
Mesotamya'yı da hallettik. Şimdi ne
kaldı? Anadolu uygarlıkları kaldı. Bu
video böyle kalsın. Uzatmanın alemi yok.
Bir de Anadolu haritası çizivereyim. Hit
Lidya Ian Urartıyı yerleştireyim. Bu
üniteyi bitirelim. Haydi bakalım.
Sonraki ders görüşmek üzere. Allah'a
emanet.
Ah.